[Music]
so the trailer for Monarch Legacy of
monsters is here and you don't have to
Wake Me Up When September Ends anymore
I'm up and add it and it will premiere
on November 17th with two episodes in
the first day and the success of ones
releasing on every Friday till January
12th meaning there will be 10 episodes
so
to the trailer the scene starts with
someone playing an old videotape
recorder digitized with the help of a
computer and I'm pretty sure this will
be Kate digging up her family's SP and
uncovering her connection with the
organization of Monarch so at the very
heart of this toy line will be her who
is portrayed by Anna saai she's the one
whom we saw in the released images near
a school bus with Godzilla in the
background we will follow her on her
journey to Japan where she will embark
on a quest to find her father who has
gone missing there amidst the chaos of
the emerging monsters and the Titans in
the world the next scene we see an old
Lee Shaw watching an old video tape of
himself in the past interacting with a
woman which might have been his old
flame probably the mother of Kate as
well probably our grandmother who knows
he seems to be saddened by the clip
meaning he was deeply attached to her
and she probably didn't live long or
died in one of her missions in the past
thus him looking heartbroken by the very
image of her face on the screen at the
same time we hear Bill randa's voice in
the background saying I don't know if
this will help you I hope so but I can't
go back in time and fix all the mistakes
I've made while showing the flashbacks
of leaw in the 1950s and probably
interacting with Bill Randa himself
there thus showing that these two were
deeply intertwined with Monarch and a
search for Titans from way back in the
1950s so in the next clip we still hear
Randa saying that he could have left
something for the future and
coincidentally at a same same time Kate
uncovers an old item of his with a tack
that has randa's name stating that it is
his property so there will be a
connection between Randa leaw and Kate
and there will be three time jumps as we
have predicted in one of our earlier
videos going back to the 1950s when
Godzilla emerged for the very first time
battling shinamura then in the 1970s
where Randa was hot on his quest to find
Skull Island which resulted in his death
there on that fateful place and yes the
more modern time frame of 2014 onward
when Kate begins to investigate and find
out her Roots as well as her connection
with both leaw and Bill Randa probably
the founders of
monar then we shift to an old clip of a
group of US military personnel in a
beach looking in a distance with a
dorsal place of Godzilla Breaking the
Waves this will be connected with the
first time the Gman makes this
appearance in modern times where the US
tries to kill him with nuclear weapons
only to feed him more energy in fact to
be fair the nukes were relatively new
weapons at that time time and the Titans
were even newer so they don't really
know or have the information that
radiation will only give Godzilla more
power instead of hurting him this
breakthrough was actually only done in
the timeline of king of the monsters
when Ser zawa revitalizes Godzilla in
his layer and this ends with a video of
Randa in Skull Island stating Just Two
Words a legacy thus the legacy of
monsters as the title of the series is
born so we now travel to Modern Times
where Lee Shaw states that the world is
on fire
and he decided to do something about it
while at the same time we see the ruins
of San Francisco in the aftermath of the
mut battle we also see him telling Kate
probably her that he might have been the
one in charge trying to kill both
Godzilla and shinamura with a nuke in
the Pacific Islands that we do know
since he was a notable character in the
comics Godzilla Awakening which
showcases the origins of the Titans in
the modern era he then continues to
state that he had a mission to protect
and delate or separate the worlds of the
m monsters and humans and that was his
job you see Kate her half brother and
the American hacker uncovering redacted
files of Monarch which had quite a lot
of information sensed about their
encounters and findings regarding the
Titans and other secret stuff the scene
then shifts to the first monster scene
in the trailer a flying creature that is
neither a Muto nor Rodan neither cot nor
Mothra or any of the other flight
capable Titans that we have seen or the
Lesser monsters it has a dragon-like
body with two fims evolved into wings
and two smaller legs ending in sharp
dinosaur andlike claws its wings bear
resemblance to that of a bat but with
more segmentations in the skin of the
wing membrane it also has a long
Serpentine Tail ending in a fog-like
design it has a short stubby neck and
though the facial features is hidden
from side at that point it seems to be
flying low to the ground just above the
canopy of the trees which tells us that
this isn't really of Titan size more in
the leak of psycho ult or the hawk from
the Skull Island series then next clip
we see a couple holding hands and it
quickly shifts into Kate in tears
probably seeing recordings of her mother
in the past and her Untold Stories the
series is stated to dive into an
intricate web of human connections
emotions and surprising relationships as
well as the monster stuff the series
will expose the mysteries of a secret
Legacy the legacy of monsters and as the
producers said days before monsters
won't just be giant creatures it will
also mean human villains and the bad
guys thus the legacy of moners will as
much be a title for the titans of the
planet as it is for a group of
individuals that sought to bring chaos
and destruction by using Sinister means
we now come to a flash bag of Lee Shaw
about to enter an armored container with
the Monarch logo on it this will
probably be for research underwater or
to see close by the effects of a nuke
against Godzilla we shift to the present
day where Kate sees an airport sign
directing people to a safe Zone in case
of another Godzilla encounter in the
city and just as they say that the
series will be back and forth between
the past and the present day we again go
to the 1950s where we see Godzilla
swimming towards an island in the ocean
which would probably be the scene of the
nuclear explosion that was seen in the
beginning scenes of Godzilla 2014 we do
know how that turned out immediately
then after we see leaw trying to
convince Kate to join him and old leaw
in the present times and if she does she
will go down the rabbit hole and get to
know everything about the secret
organization of monar as well as the
Titans we get to see another monster
after that and at first I thought Siller
but my logical sight said no Wich that
looks like kumonga and in my head I was
arguing with myself to for quite a while
while Mom looking at me in a very
concerned manner but that creature is
neither it is a Skull Island species
that looks to be a crustacean and was in
a monster battle against a mother long
leg in the background it is seen
slightly finally we would see a crab
versus spider battle like giant ones the
legs that every kid growing up wanted to
see then the scene of Bill Randa running
from something so these are probably
shots from Skull Island the movie from a
different angle we used here to tell a
different side of the same story we then
see the same flying creature from
earlier coming out from a rusty old ship
bending and breaking metal plates like
it was nothing in a short Glimpse we can
see its face and it resembles that
flying banshe from the Avatar movie we
can also see the wings again here with
the linear protusions on the membranes
that may be helping it with flight I
don't know seems odd to me but from this
we can estimate its size it looks to be
around 30 to 40 ft tall or 9 to 12 M and
with the earlier shot the wingspan could
be maybe over 100 ft wide immediately we
see the coordinates of
31.4659 know where that leads to I'm
grinning with a Sinister smile right
now that is the location of Morocco and
the Titan discovered there in Morocco is
bamit which is rumored to be a flying
Titan so this flying creature here might
be baam it
himself nice then we nearly come to the
end we then see a scene of a rusty old
ship being overturn Maybe by baffet or
by another monster well this is up for
November to tell us we then end with San
Francisco that battle there where the
military was fighting Godzilla in the
beginning trying to divert him away from
the city this is the scene where Kate
will witness the monsters for the very
first time and then this will lead her
to a slippery slope into a rabbit hole
leading to Monarch's chaotic Wonderland
by the way that shot of Godzilla is
crazy it's magnificent and
beautiful I'm not crying you are so we
have come to the end of this video a
review on the trailer of Monarch the
legacy of monsters
anyway I hope you have enjoyed it do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash the Bell
icon for regular updates of new videos
here on this channel take care fam